Laurent Garin je me tourne vers vous
vous êtes le gérant de la librairie le
pavé du canal situé à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux il s'agit de la
25e édition de la Fête de la librairie
indépendante elle aura lieu tout ce
samedi alors quel est le but de cette
journée de montrer l'importance des
librairies c'est ça qu'on soit devant la
scène comme acteur culturel et donc
cette fête vient d'Espagne en fait la
saint Jordi habituellement c'est le 23
avril cette année il y a le salon du il
y a le festival du Salon du livre de
Paris donc ils ont avancé la date mais
voilà donc c'est pour remettre la
librairie indépendante devant et pour
montrer tout l'intrait qui peut y avoir
aller en librairie indépendante et alors
qu'est-ce qui est prévu pour cette
journée spéciale pour nous en fait on va
délivrer des jolies fascicules qui ont
été éditées par les éditions gallima
donc en fait oui c'est ça c'est 25
double page où la thématique reste
autour des oiseaux voilà donc
c'est Michael caillou qui a illustré les
25 textes donc toutes les textes donc il
y a 25 autres prises donc hauteur tout
autour des oiseaux donc là c'était le
foot Bassan parce que la mer et que
j'aime bien ça et donc on va donner ça à
nos clients voilà on va leur offrir cet
ouvrage là et nous en plus on va
recevoir un scénariste de manga français
ce qui est quand même assez rare aux
éditions Cana donc on va le recevoir la
libération on va discuter un peu avec
lui si on savait de sur sa vie de
scénariste comment il crée comment
vis-à-vis du Japon ça fonctionne aussi
parce que les mangas sont très régis par
le Japon enfin c'est très compliqué de
sortir du spectre du spectre japonais
donc là voilà la France aussi qui est
une grande scène internationale du manga
on va là on va discuter avec cet auteur
là face scénariste là prend de plus en
plus de place aujourd'hui
en plus dans notre librairie nous avec
l'espace qu'on a ouvert je peux pas dire
l'inverse on a ouvert sur maintenant on
a 12000 volumes de mon gars et c'est il
y a un fort à créer sur tout style en
plus éditorial c'est ça qui est vraiment
super intéressant c'est avant c'était
vraiment très cantonné sur la jeunesse
maintenant on ouvre plein de choses à de
l'histoire énormément de choses à des
récits de vie également et donc oui le
manga est très porteur et le soir juste
pour finir et le soir on va faire du
hip-hop donc voilà c'est pour montrer
qu'une librairie indépendante ce n'est
pas qu'un commerce en fait dans une
ville c'est aussi un acteur culturel
donc on est à la croisée de couteau
qui est ici danse donc je les invite on
va pousser un peu les bibliothèques les
tables plein de livres voilà ça va être
une scène et ça va être une vraie salle
de danse c'est ça justement qui fait la
force des librairies indépendantes
aujourd'hui face aux plus grandes
librairies aux Chênes c'est ces échanges
cette semaine
c'est le fait que ce soit des personnels
formés et professionnels qui connaissent
les ouvrages et qu'on fasse pas qu'un
commerce en fait c'est qu'on est aussi
acteur culturel à proprement parler vous
avez un vrai rôle social c'est aussi
d'amener la culture aux gens qui
viennent et d'amener la lecture
également parce qu'on fait aussi partie
de l'opération qui s'appelle jeune en
librairie on accueille des collèges ou
des lycées dans la librairie donc la
classe se déplace une fois en librairie
pour qu'on leur explique la chaîne du
livre et une seconde fois où il y a un
auteur ou une autre risque qui viennent
et qui parle de leur métier donc ouais
c'est aussi ça les librairies
indépendantes et donc on est loin du
cliché le jeune nulle part il serait
très loin du cliché
complètement et en plus c'est ça qui est
intéressant pour nous c'est qu'on
apprend plein plein de choses quoi il y
a une vraie interaction qui se crée avec
également pas sculpture qui s'est mis en
place donc ça fait venir d'autres
personnes dans la librairie ça ouvre
vraiment les portes à plein de monde et
alors à partir d'octobre commander un
livre sur Internet coûtera plus cher les
frais de livraison vont passer à 3 euros
à la place de quelques centimes d'euros
c'est une bonne nouvelle selon vous ça
peut vous aider c'est une première bonne
nouvelle en fait ce que nous livrerons
indépendant on demandait en fait que la
gratuité la presque gratuite et des
frais de port soit complètement arrêté
donc là en fait c'est 3 euros jusqu'à un
panier de 35 euros dès qu'il y a un
livre en fait on peut mixer du livre et
un hors-livre donc jusqu'à 35 euros
c'est 3 euros au-delà des 35 euros ça
repasse à un centime voilà donc on va
dire que la moitié du chemin pour les
librairies indépendants est faite mais
en tout cas c'est une très très bonne
chose mais pour la librairie
indépendante pour replacer un peu à
niveau les concurrents qui peuvent
exister entre les commerces hors sol et
les commerces justement la concurrence
est érude avec les plateformes en ligne
enfin vous arrivez à vous en sortir
c'est complètement différent on
fonctionne pas du tout sur la même
créneau quoi nous on est vraiment là
pour faire des liens pour gérer de
l'humain en fait et avoir des
discussions on n'est pas des plateformes
logistiques on va là c'est complètement
différent donc on a chacun notre raison
d'être vous sentez de la vous ressentez
de la part de vos clients la volonté de
vous soutenir en allant plutôt en
librairie que de commander sur internet
avec le confinement en fait c'est
surtout là on a senti que il y avait un
fort regain en fait de popularité de
soutien en fait des gens vis-à les
commerces locaux j'ai une prise de cons
il y a une vraie prise de conscience et
en plus il y avait du temps de cerveau
disponible donc les gens se sont mis à
lire donc la conjoncture des deux a fait
que la librairie indépendance est
vraiment bien portée à la sortie du
confinement c'est une question sur ça
justement il y a eu un basculement vous
aviez mis en place des drive le drive à
la librairie du canal du papier du canal
il y a eu une vraie bascule oui avec le
confinement c'était ma question nous on
a fonctionné à plein pendant le drive
effectivement oui oui et on arrive
encore à faire des conseils par mail par
téléphone enfin voilà donc il y avait
encore ce petit lien qu'on avait réussi
à maintenir mais oui ça va bien
fonctionné face à fonctionner pendant le
confinement il y a pas dès qu'on est
passé commercial là on a repris une
activité qui était à peu près normale et
là on a repris notre place dans la dans
la ville et bien merci beaucoup Laurent
Garin d'avoir accepté notre invitation
dans les Yvelines cinq autres librairies
célèbres la fête de la librairie
indépendante ce samedi 15 avril l'année
des feuilles à saint-germain-en-lay les
petits mots à Chatou des gens qui disent
à Sartrouville les chemins du livre à
Maisons-Laffitte et le pavé dans la mare
à Élancourt
c'est un petit village la librairie
française donc oui c'est ça les amis